moi j'ai borniche un policier célèbre
célèbre écrivain le choix entre les deux
psychologiquement je préfère la police
mais financièrement parlant
je préfère le métier décrivent vous avez
quitté la police chez kia la police il
ya longtemps déjà en 1956 ce n'est pas
d'aujourd'hui
j'ai ouvert un cabinet d' enquête privée
pour le compte des compagnies
d'assurance pour déceler toutes les
tentatives d'escroquerie à l'assurance
car on pille beaucoup les assurances ou
les grandes sociétés
puis un jour on à mes amis alain delon a
demandé alors qu'il était venu à la
maison prend 20 po d'écrire mes mémoires
voilà on arrive à fric sur les voilà
j'écris fixe tories et vous écrivez
maintenant votre quatrième livre
quatrième nîmes tu vas sortir au mois
d'avril qui s'appelle le playboy et
contrairement est un flic story et à
rené la canne et aux gangs qui sont des
histoires d'un jeune inspecteur contre
les fauves d arsène lupin ou des gangs
de playboy elle en quête d'un inspecteur
le borniche colombo des années 1950 donc
celle d'après guerre où j'arrive dans la
faune argenté et dans la faune tout
court de juan les pins dans un hôtel
important tenu par un antiquaire disons
de moeurs un peu curieuse un vol
important a eu lieu et je débarque et
tout le monde est suspecte
à commencer par les victimes au départ
pour les policiers tout le monde est
toujours suspect non là c'est la victime
qui est suspecte les suspecte parce que
les 110 millions de bijoux qu'on lui a
dérobé ne sont pas garantis par une
société d'assurances
et puis et surtout parce qu'il a déjà eu
un vol précédemment et les compagnies
d'assurance ont résilié son contrat
tant le vol paraissait doute donc la
victime est suspecte
et puis la femme de la victime est
suspecte aussi car elle se promenait
avec ses bijoux non assurés sur les
plages pour les mêmes c'est bain sur les
plages de juan les pins
avec tous ces diamants autour de son cou
de ses poignets fantasy tout à fait et
puis la fille est suspecte car c'est une
petite théâtreuse et allah comme amant
un machiniste dont le passé judiciaire
est connu de la police
et puis le mari est suspecte si le mari
c'est à dire le gendre de la sophro kg
en quarts il est homosexuel et il a
comme amant si je puis dire
un monsieur qui était plusieurs fois
condamné et puis le personnel est
suspecte car le maître d'hôtel est un
ami intime des guérini c'est caïd
marseillais et ce maître d'hôtel a été
embauchée depuis deux mois seulement
l'avocat aussi est suspecte car il ya un
avocat l'avocat des mauvais garçons
détruire marseillais qui étaient là au
moment du vol on va pas raconter tous
les boys et un futur film
écoutez je n'en sais rien j'ai fait
trois bouquins trois livres donc trois
films en films
alors maintenant il faut attendre que
playboy sortent en librairie pour
connaître si l'électeur m'accordent leur
confiance d'une part éventuellement les
producteurs je viens pour vous alors est
ce qu'on peut avoir une dernière
question votre sentiment sur la police
d'aujourd'hui
eh bien il m'est difficile d'en parler
car je pense que la police actuellement
n'a plus les coudées franches comme les
avions jadis il y a eu en 1958 une
réforme du code pénal qui a sérieusement
limiter les pouvoirs des policiers et
puis le milieu a changé également il y à
une recrudescence de la criminalité
autrefois nous avions des informateurs
aujourd'hui les informateurs n'ont plus
de contact avec les policiers car à la
suite d affaires de lyon et de marseille
et vous souvenez de ces affaires
j'habille est désert les mots d'ordre
dans les ministères et dans les
préfectures et ne plus avoir aucun
l'informateur alors comme les policiers
ne sont pas des fakirs plus d'un
formateur plus d'affaires plus
d'affaires solutionner recrudescence de
la délinquance
roger borniche prochain livre nouvelle
affaire oui mais vous allez mettre en
livre toutes vos affaires policières
écoutez j'en ai quelques unes je n'ai
pas une mine d'or je suis resté pendant
dans l'administration pendant dix ans et
par conséquent j'ai à peu près dix
belles histoires à raconter alors encore
sept bons livres j'en ai un qui est
extraordinaire et que j'intitule ray
l'indiquent car justement je parlerai
l'année prochaine du problème des
informateurs ce mauvais garçon qui n'est
pas vraiment aux repentis mais qui est
quand même un mauvais garçon et qui
devient un mouton et qui sera par
conséquent aux prises avec ses anciens
confrères des milieux avec sa fin avec
sa maîtresse et surtout avec les
policiers
et avec sa conscience
[Musique]